you oughta hold them I'll hold this one
so our friend Quinton sent us some Tim
Tams fresh from Australia and when I
posted an Instagram the only thing that
people were telling me is to do a Tim
Tam slam and do you know what this is
no but I'm time to do it and we ate most
of them already we only have four Tim
Tams left what do we do I did a little
internet research and a Tim Tam slam is
when you bite the ends off of a Tim Tam
stick it in a hot beverage coffee a hot
chocolate and you suck the drink into
the Tim Tam you fill it up and I need to
stick the whole Tim Tam in your mouth
and you eat it I know right what are we
waiting for
I don't know what flavor is this gotta
get that morning see if we've got our
Tim Tam bite the end off of one so I'm
like it's melting like I was afraid no
Tim Tim slain was gonna be really a
scary thing this is like a delightful
treat I'm gonna grab my pen Pam Tim Tam
Cheers
she has mate wait I'm not ready yet
stick it in nothing moving another
covered I'm crying I don't even enjoy
yes
that was amazing holy crap you didn't
get to enjoy it you're supposed to suck
and then I managed to get a little bit
of a laugh you're supposed to enjoy it
like hell you shove it all in your mouth
you slam it I get it now my dinner is
gonna be spoiled
I honestly almost died is it is it on me
like I'm whatever
all right suit again this is great crap
if usually everything was just happening
right I can't get any coffee's too low
gotta sip Oh hope you know your dinner
just had a Tim Tam slam
I feel sick times too now the Tim Tam
slam let me know if there's I'm really
sorry for grossing you out but else
you'd like me to slam like a Twinkie you
know cute it looks like someone pooped
in your cuz poo in my cup two girls two
cups do it - thanks for watching guys
make sure you subscribe for more
fantastic videos and check out Jenna's
Channel let's meet Jenna e and uh yeah
sorry I had to watch that one sit see
you guys later
[Music]
you